[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening for London welcome to
Piers Morgan on censored reviews for
Harry and Megan's big budget Netflix
series have so far been less than kind
unimaginative and frustrating said
Hollywood's Bible variety magazine so
sickening I almost brought up my
breakfast said the woke Bible the
guardian or the intimacy of Instagrams
near the normally timid New York Times a
nauseating self-serving snooze Fest said
another pundit well that was me actually
now I guess this Deluge of derision
Netflix today released a new trailer for
the second half of this compelling
series which comes out on Thursday
viewer discretion is advised this clip
contains weapons gray hypocrisy
I wonder what would have happened to us
had we not gone out when we did our
security was being pulled everyone in
the world knew where we were I said we
need to get out of here
we are on the freedom flight
to fear this institutional gas lighting
I wasn't being thrown to the Wolves I
was being fed to the Wolves they were
actively recruiting people to
disseminate disinformation they're happy
to lie to protect my brother they were
never willing to tell the truth to
protect us Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle the Rogue Royals
they just wanted to be free
they wanted to be free to love and be
happy
I applauded that
in order for us to be able to move to
the next chapter you've got to finish
the first chapter they gave us a chance
to create that home that we had always
wanted
[Music]
I've always felt as though this was a
fight Worth Fighting For
today's new trailer makes clear that the
gloves are off in the next three
episodes of the show and remember this
is just a warm-up and this Harry's book
coming in early January
hundreds of pages of more allegations
about his family
there will be mudslinging incendiary
claims Bombshells and I fear a lot more
lies and on behalf of the British people
and the monarchy they're trashing I
intend to call out every single lie that
they utter in their attempt to not just
destroy the royal family but to
potentially bring down the British
Monarchy well joining me now is the
organizer of battle lives matter
protests Iman a former head of Royal
protection dye Davis and talk to me
presenter Sharon Osborne Over in Los
Angeles Sharon great to have you on the
program
um I don't know about you I got about
halfway through the first installment of
this wineathon last Thursday and felt
genuinely nauseous I mean I could feel
vomit Rising inside me but also a sense
of tedium like we'd heard all this
before with Oprah nothing really seemed
that new it was just a new gloss put on
all this stuff but the main purpose of
it just seemed to be to attack the royal
family to attack the institution of a
monarchy to attack Britain as a racist
country what do you make of all this
very distant distasteful peers I was
totally born by The Whining The Whining
the whining and you know the curtsy the
things she said about Medieval Times her
lunch with the queen was like Medieval
Times which as you know is a Disney type
um entertainment place for kids and it's
just so horribly disrespectful and just
a wine vest I mean what is the book
going to be the same thing whining
whining is there going to be no positive
points and that whole thing of him
um
filming himself on the freedom flight
they must have had that deal with
Netflix done months before they ever let
so the whole thing was a setup a setup a
setup why unless you had a deal why
would you have done that filming of
yourself on the plane and all of that so
what kind of Freedom video diary what
yeah and what kind of freedom is it if
all you're doing is living in your
California mansion with unbelievable
privilege and wealth and you're signing
all these deals with companies who want
their pound of Flesh and that pound of
flesh is exclusively trashing your
family
I mean this is all they do from the
Oprah interview onwards all they've done
is trash their family
it's trash but there's nothing about
themselves you know and this is a great
time for them to keep talking about
their charity but no it's about them
being these poor little children who are
so much in love and how abused they've
been their race the way they act
everything has been you know abused by
the public by the Press by the royal
family well do you know what you've got
a great life you've got a beautiful
family you're so much in love move on
get a life move on
and they just can't seem to because
they're living is by telling their truth
on the royal family that's how they make
their living yeah and their truth is
yeah I know I agree um Dave is on the
question of their security specifically
because you were obviously responsible
for a lot of Royal security for many
years Harry claims that they were sort
of had their security all taken away is
that even remotely likely to have been
true
well no the answer is absolutely not the
uh Protection Team followed them to
Canada it was when they moved from
Canada to the United States somebody far
higher than I in my present role or my
old role decided along with a committee
that decides this called ravac they
decided that it was no longer
sustainable for British police officers
to continue and I totally and utterly
agreed and can I say the last time you
and I spoke we were talking about the
Liza Uncle
um his Uncle Andrew put across and here
we are again as an investigator as you
rightly have said and many others there
are so much inconsistencies in this
there are so many half truths and my
concern is as I said having had some
information from Texas as to the number
of individuals there who have believed
this Hook Line and thinker yeah and if
you know your history of attacks on the
Royal family as I do then you would
start to realize this is potentially
very serious indeed not only for the
royal family but for a fixated person on
either side to get in touch and cause as
it did with President Reagan as it did
with their Majesty a queen last
Christmas a man with a crossbow
etc etc every year over a thousand
referrals are made to the fixated threat
Assessment Center most of them are
harmless but amongst them there is a
hardcore who could pose serious risk and
that's what I've been concerned about as
a consequence of this nonsense that's
been spewed out by these two and some of
their supporters yeah I completely agree
okay look Martin we've had some a lot of
you know animated debate about this and
I completely respect a lot of the stuff
that you've been saying vice versa uh my
issue with this is I I'm not sure what
the supposed end game is or how much
more of this was supposed to stomach I
mean this is another three hours of
trashing coming on Thursday then the
book then a series of interviews around
the book this is just a never-ending
stream of attacks on their own family
I appreciate that's how you feel but
ultimately what they're really doing is
highlighting the disgusting elephant in
the room that the majority of this
nation are more than happy to ignore and
that's what's happening right now and
they're trying to do it in a way that
allows them to look after their family
basically so if it means making money
once they do it what is that elephant in
the room
racism racism in terms of racial
Prejudice within institution and racism
in terms of this country being racist
but I said to you the other day when
things got a bit heated at this desk
that I felt that if you're going to make
incredibly serious charges of racism
in an institution like the British royal
family and the monarchy you've got to
provide some evidence they've now had a
year and a half or more since the Oprah
Winfrey interview in which they made all
these incendiary claims they've not
produced any evidence of any racism okay
so what I'm hoping is that these next
set of documentaries they will actually
provide us with some names so we can
kind of stop this what if it doesn't go
if it doesn't well what I'll do is I'll
provide you with my evidence is that all
right if you give me a minute I'll give
you some evidence as to why this that
specific institution is racist which I
can do so in terms of the evidence that
you are likely to find it is going to be
in the form of covert racism and I know
you don't like that word but it is a
fact so examples include in terms of the
institution the distribution of the
order of sense Michael which is a badge
which ultimately depicts a white man
with wings trampling a black man we can
also delve into the fact that that
institution hung up pictures of a little
black slave boy on the walls of in the
institution and everyone was so blinded
by their racial Prejudice that no one
saw fit to take it down when the that
President popped around for tea or we
can delve into the fact that the Queen
Elizabeth or rather the lake Queen made
sure that she did not have to adhere to
the equality's rules and legislation
which is arguably what a true racist
would do and we cannot take away the
facts
exactly in the true races no I'm saying
it's arguably what a true basis would do
to make sure
she couldn't have been a less racist
person okay if she had tried okay ask
anyone in any of the commonwealth
countries about the queen none of them
ever felt the queen was a racist yes
when you say things like that you lose
me I'm like that's that's a ridiculous
thing to say okay so I'll explain it so
racism was the building blocks for the
transatlantic slave trade a trade that
was funded by the royal family and they
ultimately made their wealth off of the
Bloods sweat and tears off of
enslavement hold on a second it was this
country that actually led the end of
slavery which Everyone likes hundreds of
years ago by the way but you also
contributed to it and what you fail to
realize is that the legacy of
colonialism and slavery and British
politeness a vital role in the
perpetuation of covet racism in other
words the present-day racism that I talk
about today which was in the form of
covert race so would you just so you've
described the late queen as a
effectively a true racist basically and
you think the country is racist okay so
if anyone that doesn't think that this
country is racist no no are we a racist
country or are we a country that
actually is remarkably tolerant has
extraordinary Multicultural Society but
includes some racist people which one is
it so if you don't think this is a
racist country you should probably speak
to Diane Abbott the black footballers
who have the content of racism on a
daily basis or we can delve into 85 000
people you're saying because a few
people can I just finished yeah yes or
we can delve into the 85 000 people who
reported racially motivated hate crimes
in 2021 and it's subsequently gone up to
a hundred thousand right or we can delve
into the hundred and twenty thousand
people have left their jobs in the last
five years due to racism or we can delve
into the quarter of staff and 56 of
students within higher education that
have to contend with racism or none of
those are accepted I'm happy for you my
platform
after this I have no I do not not
dispute for a moment there are vile
races in this country I don't dispute
for a moment if you trawl enough on
social media you'll find them but I do
think they are the ugly little Barnacles
peering out from rocks I don't believe
that they are actually what this country
stands for I don't believe the vast
majority of people in Britain are racist
I don't think we're an institutionally
racist country and I certainly don't
think the queen had a racist bone in her
body which is why she's such a beloved
figure in the Commonwealth so can I just
add that again I said it to you last
time this country has a very rudimentary
understanding of racism often referring
to overt racism as the defining Factor
foreign
racism is you end up with people like
Meghan Markle who say I was a victim of
racism but don't feel they have any
compulsion to have to say what actually
happened when it happened and who said
it and that is if that's covert racism
the problem with it is there's no hard
fact to support it but that's the issue
with okay so first I will preface my
statement by saying I agree with you it
should be known that's that's the fact
it should be known as she should make a
point of saying it I really do hope that
she does
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ty start from The Real Housewives of DC
cat ominay who claims she well she did
have a flick with Prince Harry doesn't
claim it I think it was true so she's
been whitewashed from history and
doesn't recognize the party Prince she
once knew cat joins me now along with
royal correspondent Vanity Fair Katie
Nichol and Fox News contributor Heraldo
Rivera welcome to you to this uh Stellar
panel I must say and thank you geralda
for joining us from across the Pod I'll
come to you in a moment cat I want to
talk to you because this book is coming
out spare it's supposed to be Harry's
story but I suspect we're going to get a
very sanitized version of anything which
is awkward for him and it'll just be
more of what we've been seeing now for
the last year and a half which is just
constant attacks on his family and the
media
or total snoozefest right I mean you
know but the title I love the title
thing is a great title but you know how
much he's influenced about how he wrote
it and what's in it who knows you were
34 when you met a young 21 year old
Harry yeah so a bit of a Madonna
situation going on there
really well she likes the toy boy isn't
she well yeah yeah I was criticized
because I didn't really care about age
you had a little fling with him uh it
was well documented and got pictures of
you there what was he like then as a
young guy
just really really really funny total
gentleman totally down to earth normal
and did he carry any of this enormous
baggage which he now appears to have all
the time because he seems just
completely miserable
he did at the time
now he just seems completely miserable
all the time this Freedom he saw it
doesn't seem to work yeah I mean what I
saw with him at the time he was
desperately searching for freedom and
and privacy and yet what he's done is
completely turned the whole situation
full circle right and now he's got no
privacy and no Freedom well they invade
their own privacy every 10 minutes
that's the sort of irony of this
position I mean Katie we thought a lot
about this um and the reason we keep
talking about it is because on Thursday
there'll be another dump of three more
episodes in this Netflix snooze Fest
which a lot of it is very boring you
said wait for it well yeah it is boring
actually it's very self-indulgent very
narcissistic but in the middle of all
this there will be more barbs we know at
the royal family and the media you know
and they'll play the oppressed victims
well it's really interesting hearing
cats say that actually because I think
when you look at those pictures of Harry
party and I started my career as a royal
correspondent because I ended up at a
party with Prince Harry and you know
drinking bottle of vodka and having a
great time and he seemed like a very fun
guy but it's interesting hearing you say
that he seemed like someone that sort of
wanted to to hide away from from the
media wanted to have his private life
and I think that is the massive
contradiction in in all of this but as I
unpick his his complaints and this
resentment and it's bitterness at the
heart of this is bitterness about the
institution bitterness about how he's
portrayed in the media and I think now
that he's actually named William in this
latest trailer and I think clearly
William and Kate and the the sussex's
relationship with William Kate is going
to come under scrutiny I think there's a
lot of sibling rivalry at the hospitals
I think Harry and the fact this book is
called spare has resented being the
spare for a long time and I think we're
going to hear much more on that
particularly I agree with you um Geraldo
across the pond
um it seems to me a lot of Americans are
as fed up with them as we are I think
you're still hanging in there as being
not necessarily a fulsome supporter but
a more tolerant uh Observer of all this
what do you make of it all
well first of all I want to say I
thought of you appears when hurricane
missed that shot I really I felt very
bad for you and for uh for England uh
thank you you know in terms of the the
Netflix uh documentary and Harry and
Megan uh you know in their participation
and you know they're they're ongoing
soap opera I really do feel for them and
I think that the vitriol being heaped on
them the the scorn is so snobby and
snotty it's having absolutely the
opposite effect I believe that they are
generating some sympathy now not because
of what they're doing on the Netflix
show as much as a reaction to the
British tabloids and this in incessant
uh constant uh you know criticism there
is no doubt in my mind that they are
they are telling the basic truth maybe
there's a you know a shot here that
should not have been used a stock
footage a footage of photograph
photographers and so forth but I think
the general truth emerges the same
sincere they seem beleaguered they seem
right in many ways
you are one of the people I most respect
in American television news you're a
hard-bitten journalist you're a war
correspondent and you've fallen for this
Guff with these two Hook Line and Sinker
because they're the least sincere people
I've ever met in my life
she's an actress she's playing a role
she's a good actress my brother I told
you peers I told you how I followed
Prince Harry into helmet Province yeah
in Afghanistan and how the American uh
Marines there and the British Personnel
that were still there after he had left
all all considered his service there to
be honorable even here no question so I
come as a reward correspondent I come
with that bias here's a guy who served
his country honorably put his own life
on the line he married a woman who for
the first time in British royal history
I was a mixed brace so the issue of
racism and here Harry's girl Straight
Outta Compton and all that kind of
baloney they have been assailed uh you
know I feel for them because they have
been targeted in a way that I feel is
very very unfair yeah
okay but I would argue they haven't been
targeted in the way that I think a lot
of Americans have been led to believe
they were targeted there was no racism
towards them in the mainstream media in
this country there wasn't the papers
here were euphoric about this The Daily
Mail the Daily Mail just did 20 pages on
the Netflix document 20 Pages
these two sought freedom and privacy in
America and all they've done since they
got there is Cash in on their Royal
titles afforded to them by an
institution they despise and are trying
to ruin and they're making hundreds of
millions of dollars
my brother served in Iraq and
Afghanistan right and in fact my
brother-in-law taught William and Harry
at Santa's Military Academy so I
absolutely respect his military service
but if my brother notwithstanding his
heroic War record in Iraq and
Afghanistan went on National Television
every 10 minutes dumping all over my
family that would be a very short
conversation next time I saw him you
just don't do that kind of thing to
families well you know
when here you have a here you have a
young couple trying to find their way an
extraordinary situations with scrutiny
that is that is so absolutely intrusive
they don't have a moment to breathe now
he is the spare he is the the one that
was designated to take over when you
know I understand all that and I
understand the frustration of that I
mean uh theoretically but I really do
believe that you are your lack of
kindness to them is laid bare peers you
can't have such a visceral uh
viciousness
he's just trying to pave their way in
the world
my response to them is driven by their
serial unkindness and viciousness to the
royal family and their deliberate
attempts now to not only attack their
family who is a beloved family in this
country but to actually destabilize and
potentially bring down the British
Monarchy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
today Harry and Megan torch what little
was left of their relationship with the
royal family and what little was left
frankly of their own reputations last
week was mostly sycophantic this latest
installment was downright seditious
Prince Harry mauls his own brother
accuses his father the new king of being
a liar even as a dig at his late great
grandmother the Queen the standing by
and doing nothing
the royal family is directly accused of
destroying two of its own to protect
itself
and I don't know where it all stops all
this
where does it end we got the book and
then we've got the interview circuit and
until it goes on
it's all apparently a dark plot by
Britain and the Royals to smear the poor
defenseless vulnerable sussexes
trickery treachery hypocrisy and if
there's one conclusion to draw from the
final installment of their Netflix
series is that Prince Harry surely is
now a traitor to the country that he
once served
William and I both saw what happened in
our in our dad's office
and we made an agreement that we would
never let that happen to our office and
to see my brother's office copy the very
same thing that we promised the two of
us would never ever do
that was heartbreaking it was terrifying
to have my brother um Scream and Shout
at me and my father say things that just
simply weren't true and and my
grandmother you know quietly sit there
and sort of take it all in they're happy
to lie to protect my brother
and yet for three years they were never
willing to tell the truth to protect us
unbelievable this blistering attack not
only on the institution of the monarchy
but also personally against the senior
Royals who represent our country around
the world is in my view Beyond contempt
in their selfish vaping attempts to
rewrite history recasting themselves as
victims these two have sold their souls
and they sold Harry's family down the
river it's unforgivable and it will
leave a bitter taste in the mouths of
millions of people
but there are toe curling moments in
this show too moments with upset even
the strongest of stomachs
if you
viewers are force-fed simpering clips of
the pair of frolicking on Californian
beaches during covid in Tyler Perry's
mansion no less While most people were
locked down many in tiny homes with lots
of children
but they were the real victims not the
thousands of people dying from a new
pandemic virus
they again cry foul of course at the
beastly horrible media for pursuing them
and wanting to take their pictures
whilst persistently throughout this new
installment showing their own highly
intrusive pictures of their own children
did they ask permission from those
children to invade their privacy for
money which is of course the very
challenge they make against the media we
also learned that Megan actually thinks
she's done Britain a favor
we get on the plane
and it's not the pilot but whoever is
sort of overseeing the crew
and he came
and he knelt next to my seat and he took
his hat off
and I just remember looking at him he
goes
appreciate everything you did for our
country
and it was the first time that I felt
like someone
saw the sacrifice
not from my own country
for this country it's not mine
sacrifice is that a joke
a sacrifice
who was this guy
who was this cabin Steward does he exist
or was he like the last one you met you
remember the Lion King premiere who told
you what a hero you were but we couldn't
find him could we will we find this
cabin Steward who apparently knelt
and took his hat off in respect for this
awesome woman who'd sacrificed so much
for our country that she's actually
caused so much damage to I'd like to
know that person exists or whether it's
just one of the cabin crew doing what
they normally do which is they kind of
crouched down don't they and they take
their hat off if they've got one on and
ask whether you want chicken or beef
that's normally what happens
we also learned that Harry can't begin
to understand why people might prefer
Catherine the Princess of Wales he of
course never complains never explains
and just does her Duty
this is how I was coming for her this is
how it's cover her if you don't see the
difference and understand why it's being
reported that way why then I can't help
you
I can't I'm sorry I just can't well I'm
joined Now by my Pat Uh Paul Barrow of
course famous Royal Butler uh Katie
nickel one of the top royal uh experts I
suppose you are aren't you and Paula Ron
Adrian
um of course is here as well so let me
start with Paul Burrell Paul
we've talked a bit about this haven't we
um about this fracturing between William
and Harry Harry's now gone on television
and called his brother William a bully
that bullied him out of the country
I've made a number of other allegations
yeah is that a liar he had to go at the
queen and everything when you watch it I
mean my jaw was dropping that he was
literally taking them all down one by
one what was your jaw doing
I was well I saw six hours of it and I
was a very saddened by all of it because
I realized that there's no way back now
for Harry he's abandoned his family he's
abandoned his duty and he's abandoned
his country and he he's disrespected his
grandmother's Legacy which is the
Commonwealth of countries which she
upheld all her all her uh through her
lifetime and you know you can't say
these things about your family and get
away with it and I don't think that
he'll ever be welcomed back here again I
think the British public will have
something to say about that and there
are certain things that came out in in
this interview which I totally didn't
agree with at all I mean he said that he
couldn't get to his grandmother he lived
literally a few hundred yards away from
her back door at Windsor Castle and
Frogmore Cottages he could have walked
up the hill gone through that door and
gone into his grandmother's sitting room
at any time and said granny I've got a
problem the Queen's door was always open
it doesn't matter about what the
courtiers say the queen would say I'm
your grandmother Harry I love you you
can come and talk to me if you have a
problem so Harry you're trying to pull
the wool over our eyes I know better
than that and the meeting at Sandringham
yes you did attend that and in that
meeting apparently Harry said to his
grandmother I'd like to stay in the
royal family and wear my uniforms and
have my Army contacts and then go back
to America and do my commercial
campaigns and the queen quite rightly
said Harry you can't have one foot in
the camper one foot out because that's
not fair to the rest of the royal family
who can't do these commercial deals who
who just do their Duty for the country
so you can't have your cake and eat it
and quite rightly the Queen the queen
herself said no yeah and so Harry went
and so he had a digger her in the
Netflix series whilst knowing that yeah
she'd recently lost Prince Philip and
that she herself was in very ill health
and has now died sadly you know the
timing of all this a buffalo is so
reprehensible Paula Ron adri look you've
always defended but Paul just hang on
one sec yes I always defended Harry yeah
I'll come back to you Paul I'm talking
to Paula just quickly about this you've
always defended them
surely when you watch that latest stuff
today
watching anybody take down their brother
their father their grandmother
on television
it's not a good thing
it's not a good thing but I have always
said to you peers that this is only
going to get worse unless we stop and
start listening what you are witnessing
are people who believe that they have
been treated badly whether you believe
them or not whether you want to shout at
them or not whether you want to deny
them or not whether we want whether you
want us to listen to 12 minutes of you
telling us how awful they are is human I
think they are awful but that may well
be your opinion but you're here to give
me yours right I'm different yeah and
what is happening so I mean you're
entitled to say whatever you want well
of course and so are they and so are
they yes and that is what they are doing
that is what they feel they have been
they can say what they like they do when
they do what they do but when they do
what they do we are entitled in this
country when our country is put under
attack like this and branded a racist
country by these two
with a racist royal family of the head
of it we are entitled to defend what
this country I know about the Institute
that is the royal family we've seen what
happens when somebody calls out a member
of the Royals royal household and says
that they are racist what happens to
them well they have to stop working they
have to close who is racist uh well we
know that there was the incident with
Miss with Lady hussy
she was removed from office within 24.
we won't forget she was removed the
moment because she was made accountable
of what who was racist and Megan and
Harry it could have been lady you don't
know dear it could have been said he was
a member of the family it could have
been somebody else and so what we're
doing we're told is could be any of them
so they're all all Smith by association
and as I've said we can keep shouting
but the fact is they are hurting and we
are witnessing them
you say they're counting their money
yeah I mean look you're not criticizing
Mike Tyndall for being on I'm a
celebrity are you or doing adverts with
Amazon or dominoes or whoever it is he's
doing is not a paid up member of the
royal family he doesn't get anything
from the tax base not now
what they've done money no no hang on
they've given up Royal Duty and they've
left the country in the family but what
they haven't given up is the Royal
titles which now make them all the money
what I was just about to say the point
of Royal titles they listen they are
entitled to have their opinion if they
absolutely
hate The Establishment they hate well
they've left Britain right they've stood
down as working Royals and I think there
is a real issue with them holding on to
those titles very clear to see from
everything that we've seen in Netflix
that without that Royal calling card
there is nothing that no one is no one
is actually interested in what they have
to say about anything else
if they hate the institution so much if
if it's racist and bigoted and
everything else then do what they
actually said and this was new because
this was one of the new things that did
come out of today they offered to return
those titles if their version of a half
in half out monarchy didn't work so they
put that off on the table if they have a
shred of dignity left put that offer
back on the table and follow why would
you want to be in a racist institution
so why would why would a black police
officer want to be part of of the police
Metropolitan Police why would a black
female fire often want to be a part of
the London Fire why do they want to be
the Lord do it you do it
they are in pain
causing pain they're inflicting Pains
come on there's more they're the ones
doing all the ability victim blaming
this is a classic when you blame it back
and look at what's happening they're not
victims what you are hearing and what
I'm hearing is an app salute tsunami of
denial denial denial
anything that comes out of their mouth I
don't believe it so I want to hear you
say that absolutely everything that has
come out of Harry and Megan's mouth is a
lie I think a lot of it is actually yeah
if there is some if there is some truth
in what they've got to say should we not
be worried there was a clip today which
I thought completely sum them up there
was Tyler Perry for some random reason
he'd never met and decides to give him
his Mansion so they're living in this
vast Mansion during the covert pandemic
which you think they might feel lucky
about but no no they're moaning away
about that too and Tyler Perry uh is
talking over footage and saying they've
been abused by their status in the royal
family and the footage shows a sneaky
Paparazzi craning down from a rooftop
taking pictures of them with their child
only it wasn't a Paparazzi it was a
royal photographer who had been
accredited and approved by them to take
those pictures on an official tour so it
wasn't what it seemed it was a lie
they're the producers of this series
they know it's a lie and they put it in
there so that people fall for this
claptrap rather like we saw the vast
Army of Paparazzi aiming at some event
but it wasn't it was a Harry Potter
Premiere they weren't even there it was
five years before he met Meghan Markle
all of it is smoke and mirrors and on
the really incendiary stuff no evidence
who is this person at the palace that
said to Meghan Markle I don't care that
you're feeling suicidal you don't get
any help why didn't Harry get her the
help if she was genuinely suicidal who
is the racist in the palace they still
won't tell us these are serious
allegations causing serious damage to
our royal family and this country's
reputation and it's not good enough that
they keep going on television spray
gunning everybody again and they don't
give us the actual facts
have been incredibly Brave take him on
an Institute
to take them down and you should get
around two institutions that I'm afraid
they're trying to take down and this is
this is a blatant attempt to take down
but they won't succeed and I think the
Royal Family's dignity in maintaining
its silence and that showed togetherness
tonight is actually what people want
people I think people are just switching
off people to believe that they're all
family are keeping a dignified silence
we know that that's not true
[Music]
final question just to Paul before we
let you go Paul you've been around the
royal family a very long time what will
the royal family be feeling about all
this
they'll be appalled by all of this
washing dirty laundry in public it's not
their scene and they will close ranks
they will hold it together with dignity
and you're quite right that's what we
expect them to do
um don't attack Kate and William because
they are our future king and queen right
case has never put a foot wrong don't
attack her she's she's the jewel in our
Crown right now and she deserves our
respect and admiration and had
unbelievable criticism early on actually
which everyone can be interested against
you don't see any of that in the series
all just about negative for Megan
positive for okay total lies absolute
lies no thank you fasten your seat belts
though we've got the book to come right
or 400 Pages
this never stops right thank you Katie
good to see you thank you Paula always
good to hear the other view uh I don't
agree with it but I respect your right
to have it I heard from this guy well
still to come tonight and look at the
division it causes here as well they've
launched a load of Divisions was Meghan
Markle made a scapegoat for the Royal
Rift or were the fault lines when Harry
and William there already we'll debate
that next well where did it all go wrong
all of this leaves a deeply unpleasant
taste
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
show because this is a subject that gets
people's passions fired up what's
becoming clear is that Meghan Markle is
definitely not alone in her delusional
victimhood Harry seems even more bitter
and twisted about it all and wants us to
think he's an even bigger victim in his
relationship with his brother William is
now likely torched beyond all repair
well where did it all go wrong according
to the Sussex version of events their
truth which is very rarely the truth
says that Meghan Markle was scapegoated
by the palace because she was get this
too popular whilst at the same time
being so criticized
I think Australia was a real turning
point because they were so popular
so popular with the public
[Music]
the internals at the palace were
incredibly threatened by that she's
becoming a royal rock star figure I
would argue as a couple than William and
Kate that's probably not a good thing in
the long term it's a dirty game
you know there's leaking but there's
also planting of stories you just see it
play out like a story about someone in
the family would pop up for a minute and
they go I've got to make that go away
but there's real estate on a website
homepage there is real estate there on a
newspaper front cover and something has
to be filled in there about someone
Royal
I've seen little cartoons of me on all
fours with her
um holding a dog lead and me wearing the
dog collar how predictable that you know
the woman is to be blamed for the
decision of a couple in fact it was my
decision
she never asked to leave
I was the one that had to see it for
myself but it's misogyny at its best
all doormats say that kind of thing
don't they well joining me now the
author and historian Tessa Dunlop
journalist and columnist Maureen Callum
because the former conservative Minister
who gets a mention in the series uh Ann
Whitaker welcome to all of you or in
Canada what is the view in America about
us I'm hearing a worrying number of
Americans falling for this claptrap
including it turns out Beyonce who's
sent this ridiculous text message to
Meghan Markle after the Oprah winathon
now saluting her courageous brilliant
stand against well we've got to hear I
think
Beyonce just texted
really meant
shut up just checking in
he's checking in just casual I'm still
guess
she knows who I am
no it's okay she said
she wants me to feel safe and protected
she admires and respects my bravery and
vulnerability and she thinks I was
selected to break generational curses
that need to be healed
that's all said
yeah even the dog is calling [ __ ] on
that uh Maureen
um what do you think what do you make of
this what does America make of this do
most rational Americans see through this
oh Piers yes please again let me
reassure you Beyonce would be in the uh
minority opinion of these two I think we
are all
well and thoroughly exhausted by this
endless moaning and whinging and banging
on you know and the hurling of vague
accusations I mean all this time later
all of these podcasts and interviews and
now this six-parter and a book to come
and we still have no Smoking Gun what
are they waiting for
well there is no smoking gun is there or
we would have heard it by now
um
endless rehashing of the same old wines
they're they're very very very in love
with their grievances their victimhood
it's a very strange psyche they seem to
share you know you were talking earlier
about you know is how much Harry may be
to blame but I really think in Megan he
found someone to really unlock I think
years of rage and resentment and
jealousy because this is like a tsunami
it just keeps coming and coming and
coming and the constant comparisons to
his mother actually I found I gotta say
pretty distasteful because in my
estimation I've known them both both
women no comparison whatsoever is valid
between Meghan Markle and Princess Diana
and Diner's Fame was stratospherically
bigger as was the attention that was
afforded to it all right you've been
seething and waiting to get stuck into
me all night come on I mean you do you
are the tangible proof that this is a
dirty green because you helped make it
carrying on spreading the muck all
around like a little kid who's done a
poo and wants to look at it
hang on calm down actually it's them
spreading the mug they're the only
members of the royal family doing any of
the talking they're the ones on all the
TV stations and TV series and podcasts
and books spray gunning their family our
royal family our monarchy and my country
Britain running is a bunch of callous
races come on they are the ones
spreading the dirt deep puff your
patriotic chest
I'm going to explain to you they've made
it very clear that actually I thought
they were very coded and careful when
they called out rarely incidentally you
have to sit through a long three hours
to find any specifics on William or
Charles they're very careful to Target
most of it at the fourth estate
particularly the Associated Press which
they had a victory over in the courts
well it was settled and and then then
they won the appeal Harry Potter Harry
claimed the Daily Mail was was actually
responsible for his wife's miscarriage
without providing a shred of evidence
that that was true I send you that line
off there that was a classic case of a
vulnerable man who's fighting a
difficult case feeling like more
eventually
putting two and two together and
equaling fight or event or revengeful
vindictive man who actually says he
hates the press and media attention but
has just invaded the privacy of his
family in spectacular fashion because a
a streaming platform has paid him a
hundred million dollars there's a word
for that and it is hypocrisy peers what
he did was call out and he referred to
it as the symbiotic relationship between
the press and the royal family he is
well within his rights to do that and
we're wanting our rights to judge the
reason that I feel Keen tonight to hold
you to account sure is that as we heard
in that documentary you were a big
player a giant mouthpiece for literally
stirring or if I made [ __ ] stirring
Harry and Megan are bigger than Kate and
William oh that's gonna say stable I
think oh let's just throw in a match and
watch it blow up that's what you did
like the kid with his finger in the diet
waiting wiggling till the flood comes
calm down
I'm not car you don't have to be calm
I'm just saying if you come then I can
respond which is to say that up to the
point they got married I was very
supportive of them including on their
wedding day writing a very very
supportive piece for the men on Sunday
actually about how brilliant it was to
see a biracial wedding finally in the
royal family it was only when their
behavior changed when they became a
Serial pair of Hypocrites wanting their
Royal cake and eating it preaching about
stuff they did the complete opposite
with that I turned against it let's go
let's go down to around Whitaker and you
get mentioned in the series were you
expecting that and what was your
reaction
honestly appears it gave me the greatest
belly laugh that I've had since Neil
kinnick fell in the sea I mean it was
unbelievable
I I made an adverse comment about Megan
on Celebrity Big Brother now as you know
Celebrity Big Brother you're completely
cut off from the rest of the world you
know I hardly had the palace on the
phone and apparently the fact that I had
made this comment which was my own
genuine opinion uh is all part of it's
It's proof of that the conspiracy uh
that there was uh to discredites
my own opinion let's watch the clip
actually for the viewers who didn't see
it let's watch the clip from Celebrity
Big Brother
but there's real estate on a website
homepage there is real estate there on a
newspaper front cover and something has
to be filled in there about someone
Royal what do we all think about Meghan
Markle I love Nick I think she's very
beautiful no I love it okay let's take a
vote I think she's troubled why do you
think she's travel Anne grand
um
attitude I I worry she's older than him
yeah
she's been married before yeah
I added all up and I'm uneasy there we
go
well you weren't wrong were you Ann
whittakam um because she was she's a lot
older than Harry five years older she's
a divorcee the last husband heard it was
all over I think when she sent the Rings
back in the mail
um and she comes barreling into the
royal family picks up a handsome prince
and before we know it drags him back to
California to turn into a money machine
and they disown both their families that
I would say that is the person
personification of trouble
well absolutely as I say 10 out of 10
for prophecy on my part uh but I think
it's very clear what's gone on uh Megan
wants the lifestyle of an A-list
celebrity but she's never risen above
um apart uh in a TV soap opera uh and uh
Harry uh wants all the trappings of
royalty without actually uh the slog of
the duty that goes with it and that's
what they want
um and that's what you know all this is
about it's about making money from the
only thing that they've got which is
their Royal connections I've got nothing
else they've got nothing else make money
attacking an institution that you
exploit for personal gain it's quite
breathtaking uh I've got to leave it
there whatever you up to tonight Keep It
Uncensored that's it from Delight good
night
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you